and not like the other distant family
and had the first panel discussion
Warren Buffett is the chairman and CEO
of Berkshire Hathaway
he's a extremely admired businessman and
investor he's been enormously generous
and helped me put this conference
together Robert rice is the former
Secretary of Labor the 22nd Secretary of
Labor a man who is responsible for
helping Americans earn our living
keeping our workplace safe and led I
think a successful cause and learning us
to the problem with sweatshops
throughout the world and helping us
reduce the exploitation of Labor on this
planet Ted Sorensen a Nebraskan who
needs relatively little introduction he
was a console to President John
Fitzgerald Kennedy he's widely published
as an author on the presidency and
foreign affairs
he practices international law as a
senior partner in the New York law firm
of paul weiss rifkind wharton & garrison
larry shimmerin is chief economist and
managing director of the economic
strategy institute in washington DC he
headed up the economic forecasting for
IBM was chairman of chase econometrics
and is also an author of several books
and articles and a frequent guest on
several national news programs Jill
docking is a partner at AG Edwards in
Wichita Kansas and as such has a front
row seat into the investments that are
being made by individuals and families
in the heartland she was also the United
States Senate in Kansas in 1996 I talked
her into that experience and spite that
fact I hope she still considers me as
called some friends I
what I've asked the panel to do and I
will and will invite you when they're
when they're through making opening
statements to do as well is try to
answer the question does trade impact
American lives does it have any effect
upon of the men and women of the million
men and women for example in Nebraska
who have jobs about 80,000 of which
depend directly upon trade that leaves
about 900,000 that do not at least in
the obvious way depend directly upon
trade so I begin Warren just start with
you I know that the you know as well
there's a lot of Nebraskans that are
insured they're very unsure about what
our trade policy should be skeptical of
it and I just ask you you think it has
an effect on is positive or negative
well I would say the answer to that is
yes incidentally I learned something
every time Bob talks and some of those
revelations are more exciting than
others and I just learned on this
introduction that that people who speak
on trade receive high fees that was a
that was not covered in the earlier
material at that they the answer of
course is that it it trade affects
everyone and and and it affects in the
short run it certainly affects some
people negatively at unquestionably over
the longer term has a enormous ly
beneficial effect on the standard of
living of the American people as a whole
but in the process it produces it can
produce significant dislocations because
competition and capitalism can be brutal
and when someone finds a way to do
something that you were doing more
efficiently at lower cost it's very
unpleasant for you no matter how
pleasant it may be for tens of millions
of other consumers who buy that product
at a lower price subsequently and often
those the impact will be on people who
were either of an age or
who have abilities that limit their
employability at comparable wages or
maybe at all even elsewhere I've been in
the textile business I'm in the shoe
business and if under a doctrine of
comparative advantage that goes back
centuries I don't know was it Ricardo
that came up with it's been a long time
since I've been in school I think it
shows but it it is good for the
consumers of shoes or textiles if the
the unit cost of those items can be
brought down by either people of greater
skill or machinery or lower wages
enabling those products to be sold
cheaper but if you're someone that's
been thirty years in New Bedford working
in the textile industry and all you know
is is how to run a loom or if you've
been in the shoe business and all you
know how to do is is so uppers you have
a problem and frankly the the job of
government seems to me is to promote
trade which will raise the standard of
living of the country and at the same
time have a safety net for those who are
dislocated by by the the product of free
trade and to the extent that retraining
is possible that's obviously the best
solution there will be times when
retraining won't do the job I mean you
really need a policy that takes care of
people who lose jobs through no fault of
their own the people that own the plants
can usually take pretty good care of
themselves but the the person has been
out there thirty years on the job and
those ones skill when one skill only and
is not a great prospect for retaining
and retraining at 55 or thereabouts
really needs a safety net and
fortunately this country has the
resources to provide a safety net we
have the national output to take care of
everybody in this country including
those who are
less fortunate for a variety of reasons
whether it be health or lack of the
ability to compete in a free market
economy well or people who were thrown
out of jobs that the only jobs they've
known for thirty years we have the
resources to do that we have to supply
those resources in that manner and not
have a policy that says we're going to
protect the job we have to protect the
person but not the job and that's going
to cut both ways in a place like
Nebraska we have a steel mill up and up
in Norfolk and it's being hurt right as
we talk today bye-bye steel imports most
people don't think we have steel in
Nebraska but we do and we will have
there were a billion pairs of shoes sold
in this country five years ago which is
about the last time I looked at
statistics I buy one pair about every
five years but we apparently have a
number of relatives of Imelda Marcos or
somebody that out there and so we we
sell a billion pair and as of five years
ago 150 million pair were made in this
country it's it's undoubtedly far less
now and the truth is that you can in
many cases and most kinds of shoes you
can bring them in cheaper then you can
make them here and if the only thing you
know how to do is make shoes you've got
a problem but the country still wants to
it wants to use our our comparative
advantage where we haven't we want
others to use it we want to get the most
Goods in relation to the unit labor
that's expended and and and we should
encourage all polyamide view encourage
all policies that that cause that and
then we should take very good care of
the people that that get penalized
because of that policy
sure let me let me agree with Warren's
comments and those made by Bob rice at
lunch I think all of us would agree that
real two-way free trade is a net plus
for the US economy it generates higher
living standards by providing more
consumer choice lower prices rising
productivity higher real incomes and it
generally raises living standards for
the population at large it raises the
question though as you saw on the tape
and in the survey that Bob Rice referred
to at lunch if that's the case why is
there a sort of growing backlash against
free trade in this country why is there
sort of creeping protectionism why don't
people recognize the benefits of free
trade and I think there are two or three
reasons some of what you've already been
mentioned today number one the benefits
are uneven there are always some losers
and number two the losses or the losses
are much more obvious you can identify
when someone loses a job because a plant
he was working in or she was working in
is moved to Mexico or somewhere else the
benefits tend to more evenly dispersed
it's hard to measure how much of the
productivity gains we get come from
exports or free trade but I think
there's another reason and I think you
also saw that on the tape earlier and
that's the issue of whether or not we
really have free trade the debate on
trade is all often oversimplified by
portraying people as either a free
trader or protectionist but there are
different kinds of free trade in my
judgment there's the two-way real free
trade which the textbooks talk about in
which most countries are better off net
gains for all countries and the one way
free trade that characterizes a lot of
US trade relationships currently
particularly our relationships with Asia
Japan China and some other Asian
countries and I think that accounts for
the concerns in this country regarding
trade and in my opinion while it's clear
that two-way free trade is a net plus it
isn't so clear that one-way free trade
is and I think you all know the kinds of
things I'm talking about the ongoing
export led growth strategies that many
Asian countries employ keeping their
domestic spending down generating a high
level of domestic savings which is used
to finance more capacity expansion
largely in a growing number of
manufacturing industries to support high
and rising levels of exports close
markets in many parts of the world an
integral part of that export led growth
strategy that many Asian countries
employ currency manipulation in many
countries accumulating dollar reserves
in order to keep their currency is
undervalued to help them expand their
exports and hold down their imports a
number of other trade practices at the
Boeing example where China insists that
a Boeing is going to sell jet aircraft
in China they have to produce part of
the aircraft there and Boeing really has
no choice but to do it even though it
may not be in their best interest even
though they might prefer for competitive
reasons to do it here in the United
States this is the issue and in my
judgment until this issue was
effectively addressed we're likely to
have ongoing structural trade deficits
in this country which get a lot worse
over the next year because of the
recessions in these countries and I
think spread or lead to this continued
creeping protectionism I mentioned a
moment ago and if I could just answer
quickly the question that barb Kerry
raised at lunch when he opposed the
question to bob rush what should the
objective of trade policy be in the
United States
much like the objective of budget policy
should be balancing the budget which may
or may not be the right objective
certainly it isn't all the time in trade
in my judgment the objective should be
equal access opening markets overseas
reciprocity and dealing with the other
trade issues that have created this sort
of one-way free trade if we're going to
get the full benefits of trade for the
United States economy and if US workers
are going to benefit from this trend
toward globalization I think that's an
absolute must
thanks for comments can you bring this
thing down the street level pockets off
how you see Trey
I see drink yes Allison technology Bob
we've been real fortunate with our
bargaining and our wages sitting up
there so we see our co-workers in other
unions not so lucky like you're be
packing plants that don't pay a living
wage anymore now they don't even have
American workers there they're bringing
people in the illegally in this country
though and that doesn't help us we need
a living wage and as long as they import
products from overseas and undersell us
then it's not going to happen we need
you know but there is a disconnect
between on the one hand what the élysée
including the business community
academic admissions a lot of people in
Washington say about trade that it's
good the immigration is basically good a
disconnect between all of that and what
the average working American feels about
trade and also immigration and over a
bunch I alluded to a recent poll that
appeared in The Wall Street Journal on
December December 10th and I think it's
useful for us to face this squarely
because remember this is at a point in
time in our economic history in which
unemployment is down at four point four
percent nationally I don't know what the
figure is in Nebraska I think it's
probably very low we have very healthy
economic growth and we have almost no
sign of inflation certainly no
accelerating inflation
we've not had this good an economic
climate and economic picture in 30 to 35
years and yet according to this random
sample poll 58% of Americans said that
foreign trade is bad for the US economy
because cheap imports hurts wages and
jobs seventy-two percent of Americans
said we should not increase immigration
because it will cost us jobs and
increase unemployment now that gap
between elite perceptions and by elite
perceptions I mean again people who talk
most of the time on the television who
are academics who are in Washington who
run businesses people who say trade is
good overall and also immigration within
certain bounds is good and we could even
have some more and the business
community recently wanting more
high-tech workers to come in the
agricultural community wanting more
agricultural workers to come in the
difference between that and average
working people is growing that gap is
growing and when and if we have an
economic recession and I don't mean to
be gloom and doom about it but I think
it's very likely that at some point this
recovery will end business cycles do
tend to run in cycles after all the
probability is that even more Americans
will say no to trade and certainly no to
immigration this state Nebraska and I
don't mean to be presumptuous because I
am not from Nebraska but from what I can
tell from the data I've seen this state
does depend on trade exports
agricultural exports are very important
to this state other exports are very
important to this state but people here
are nervous with some reason and just to
underscore what Warren was saying and
what Larry was saying also we've got to
make people secure enough that if they
are on the losing side of trade they
still feel they have a fair chance of
getting on the winning side and right
now more people have no health insurance
than had in 1992 a larger percentage of
our people are without health insurance
a larger percentage have no
pensions outside Social Security than in
1992 more people lack good affordable
daycare than in 1992 this is all more
people are insecure than before this
recovery began and the median wage the
wage of the People smack in the middle
of the income ladder is not adjusted for
inflation higher than it was in 1992
before where just as the recovery was
getting going there's been a very uneven
recovery and that sense and the people
who feel that they are on the losing
side are most likely the people who feel
that they are either the losers from
trade and immigration or most likely to
be the losers or in danger of being the
losers from trade and immigration one
final point quickly Larry says I think
with some justification that we ought to
demand that other countries play by the
same rules and we certainly should do
that but I want to make sure that we
understand that we live in a glass house
before we throw stones when we accuse
other nations of subsidizing their
industries take a look at the recent
four-part Time magazine series on
corporate welfare in the United States
when we accuse other nations of not
having adequate transparency in terms of
understanding what investments are doing
and where investments are going take a
look at hedge funds in the United States
particularly long-term capital and the
fact that we have no idea what these
hedge funds are doing when we complain
in this country about other countries
preventing our goods from getting in
take a look at the voluntary restraint
agreements so-called voluntary they
anti-dumping complaints all of the
countervailing duties that we in the
United States are imposing unilaterally
on other countries I'm not saying that
they are more responsible by from my
eyes within us than we are I'm simply
saying that we have got to take a very
hard an honest look at our economy as
well as demanding from others that they
play the game appropriately
more detail on it while the cheetah was
talking about in Nebraska we have a
hundred thousand of our million jobs are
dependent upon cabbage growing feeding
processing story it's transporting they
are number one industry twenty five
thousand men women who are employed in
the meat packing industry one hundred
and three or four total a company
statewide a lot of a very small sliver
by large and what she is talking about
is that over the last twenty years those
jobs have gone from washing job jobs to
entry-level jobs and increasingly a big
fraction the Damien later on about
looking church to talk about and a large
fraction are many women who see $7 or $8
or $9 an hour opportunity they're coming
to the United States from Mexico and if
they maybe those suspicions that
surrounds this whole issue as a
consequence we have McAdams to be a very
big issue with Canada and desire for a
remedy or some time when suspicions
exists that in this particular case that
cattle are being done in the United
under under under possible axioms
another question are there are there
reasonable remedies that don't lead us
into the trade and is there maybe later
respond their concern about this issue
you probably had some experiences as
labor secretary and so I just asked Ted
I don't want you messing sort of get off
and talk to us about cap let me first
correct your introduction when you refer
to the experts on this panel unlike
Larry and Bob and the others I I'm not
an economist I have no expertise and
Finance monetary policy but I'm from
Nebraska that gives me an edge over all
of them let me just say as simply as I
can what I think we have to understand
and this is true when we talk about
Canada which is one of the largest
markets for Nebraska exports in the in
the whole world or whether we're talking
about Mexico which is another one of our
major export markets are that we can't
have it both ways we can't continue to
lead the world politically if we try to
retreat from the world economically we
can't to continue to sell our cattle and
our grain to Asia if we don't continue
to buy its textiles and automobiles we
cannot continue to keep making our
inhabitants for the most part richer and
richer while the most of the world is
getting poorer and poorer
we cannot preach the virtues of free
trade while telling our citizens they
cannot buy foreign choice if they happen
to be cheaper or telling other countries
that they cannot sell to those countries
who we disapprove of
politically in Nebraska and in the
country as a whole we grow far more food
than we can eat and we watch far more
television sets than we can make it's
one world we can send a bushel of wheat
from Sidney Nebraska to Seoul Korea far
more easily today than we could send it
to the Birmingham Alabama a generation
ago a Nebraska farmer can be far more
threatened by a bank failure in Tokyo
today than he was by a bank failure in
Toledo Ohio during the Great Depression
the price of Nebraska corn falls when
the export of American corn falls when
the purchasing power of Thais and
Malaysians and Indonesians Falls I am an
example of this one small world that we
live in I'm I make my living basically
helping facilitate deals many parts of
the world I have learned from long
experience that a a deal a contract will
endure only if both sides gain and both
sides do gain and both sides gain if
trade is expanding provided it's
expanding by the rules so I think that
yes I think we there are steps that we
must take and we can come to this later
about those who are left behind because
some are and there are laws that must be
enforced to make sure that everybody
does play by the rules but basically
protectionism instead of protecting
simply prevents our workers from getting
those higher paid jobs and exports
prevents our consumers from getting
lower cost and frequently higher quality
goods that are made elsewhere and for
the York friends above in the Congress
to not properly fund the IMF or to
reject the rule
the World Trade Organization or to not
pay our back dues in the United Nations
is simply being unreal and retreating
from the world we have to live one of
the things that I do here will trade
blows disruptions in international
markets in fact on my security in
retirement my planning for those years
when I go to work yeah I want to follow
up a little bit of Ted's comment on
everybody here being an expert the
reason I am here is because they were
looking for somebody who was the average
American and I just want you to notice
that they picked a Kansan in a dish in
addition to that I think it's because
Senator Bob Kerrey wanted to see what a
Jayhawk would look like dressed up as a
Gore investor
I am a stockbroker in Wichita Kansas and
I will answer the Senators question but
before I was asked to sit on this panel
the question I was asked was you know
how do you think the Asian crisis
affects average Americans so I actually
took some time this week and called a
number of my clients who are small
business owners or operators I look at
all you young faces out here if you are
gonna stay in Nebraska or in the Midwest
you are more than likely going to be in
small business not employed by large
corporations so to me when the Asian
crisis and the international issues
hipped small businesses in Kansas in
Nebraska we have something that affects
the grassroots their answers were
interesting of course in Kansas we are
very concerned when Boeing lays off
3,000 people because Boeing is our
largest private employer but I can see
that the Asian crisis and the
international crisis is beginning to
reach small businesses like Nebraska
anything involved with commodities has
been hurt very hard in Kansas in rural
Kansas we are probably at a deep
recession slash almost depression point
in the oil industry because we are small
producers it's very expensive to produce
oil we have oil companies closing we
have the supply stores that supply those
oil companies closing those people are
probably getting other jobs but I assure
you they are not being paid what they
were paid in the oil patch they are
going to service sector jobs the second
piece is manufacturing and there is a
piece we have to recognize Sheila when
you talk about international business
there is a piece of the manufacturing
sector in Kansas who is benefitting by
the Asian crisis I have a client that
makes dog collars they import the steel
buckle that goes on those dog collars
and in Taiwan they are getting the
advantages of this deep recession in
Taiwan because the steel is very cheap
for them
to import only 10% of their cost is
labor so 45% of their cost is this steel
and it's becoming very cost efficient
for them but Larry brought up a good
point the second part of that is because
we have a tariff on the webbing they by
domestic webbing and this gentleman said
to me you know what in the short term
the Asian crisis is very good for us but
if this keeps going on we're gonna look
at leaving America because if this
continues to go on in the price that of
our imports gets lower and lower and
lower and the Asians come up with a
better webbing than they have before it
makes more sense for us to move to
Mexico because they are charged a tariff
on the material they're bringing in but
we do not charge a tariff of bringing a
finished product back into the United
States of America so do we have free
trade I don't think we have free trade I
don't think we have consistency in that
free trade and what Larry said is a very
good point because it is going to draw
people from Wichita Kansas to move to
Mexico so with that in my corn Husker I
will open it up to defining the Asian
economy Nebraska
noticing applying exports and declining
prices as a consequence of slowing the
demand is also the potential loss of
jobs of the PT's with people saying I'm
this move as a result saying low wage
opportunities are low cost to
opportunity so it becomes a potentially
a double-billed threat for us to and
spawn to Laurie sitting there are things
we don't harass me very well is that
perhaps our most important resource our
farm was the last foundation was on an
issue having to do with the short grain
come over cost per shift I want you to
Alabama boy you Montreuil supporting
work my personal opinion I definitely
agree with Larry's idea we do not have
free trade amongst international trade
my business I am merchandise grain also
and I'm from what I have seen in the
last year I think it's very important
that we find an answer to to the ability
to trade with the Asian companies or
Asian countries we've seen the
devaluation of their money and we can't
export anything to them and just I think
we're going to see that back up
everywhere from a farm life we farm in
agriculture basically we like the style
of life yeah I could live in Omaha I
could make a lot of money doing
something else but there's there's a
something you get from living in the
country that you
can you from Omaha and that's basically
where we as Nebraskans have come from
and if we don't find an answer to this
I think we're eventually going to lose
that lifestyle it's really the
politicians nightmare because it it is a
problem that where you have a trade-off
of diffused benefits over a long term
and specific and intense pain to a
limited number in the short term and
that when you are deciding public policy
on issues that give you those choices it
can get very very tough I mean just just
assume that 80 years ago or so that when
the tractor was coming in that horses
could vote now I've never been a horse
although I've been accused of being a
certain portion of their Anatomy maybe
but but I think you could I think you
could say without undue presumption that
the horses would not have voted for the
tractors now the consumers would have
voted for the tractors though the
tractors were going to make food you
know which every American consumed could
make the food cheaper very diffused
benefit not immediately seen might be
attributed to something else if the
price of bread went down a penny or two
off but every horse would know what was
happening and you could say well we're
going to retrain you to be a show horse
or we're going to turn you into a you
know into a six furlong gem or something
of the sort but the horses as a whole
particularly the older horses would know
that this was not good news and what you
face and you really do face it as a
policymaker you face unquestioned
specific intense pain on the part of
people that find their jobs displaced
and you have a very diffused very
substantial benefit
that no particular constituent is going
to give you credit for if it happens and
you're going to get blamed for the pain
if a trade policy intensifies what I've
been talking about in medicine you know
that is that that is the issue that that
has to be faced I say that you go for
the social benefits over time for
society as a whole but you just have one
hell of a rest home for the situation
trying to say earlier with the Canadians
is are very sort of mild it's a very hot
issue it's not really an issue of
competition it's an issue of a of a
government policy that makes it
difficult for us to get to that
competition apparently either let me
make a couple of comments on that and
first one of the points that Ted made by
the way Ted I noticed when you said you
weren't an economist you had a big smile
on your face aren't you an attorney
couple of comments I don't know I know a
lot of people in the economics
profession and outside of the profession
I don't know anybody I would call it
true protectionist and I think I said
this earlier if you believe in free
trade as I do but I suspect suspect most
people in this room do the biggest
threat to free trade right now is the
current structure of the trading system
and the threat will increase
dramatically over the next year or two
because as all of us said several times
already today the trade deficit is now
going off the chart partly because of
the Asian crisis partly because of some
of the long-term structural problems we
talked about earlier more jobs are going
to be lost by export oriented companies
we've seen only the early stages of that
more will be displaced by increased
imports again we're seeing only the
early stages of that
so the backlash against trade is likely
to rise dramatically if we're not
careful and if we don't deal with the
real issue the issues that I try to
describe earlier now how do we do it
what and by the way again on text point
look we're not perfect but our markets
clearly are far and world open and have
always been in almost any other country
around the world particularly those that
we engage in with high levels of trade
currents so while we should keep our
markets open
we're Saints compared to everyone else
even though we're not perfect what do we
do about short term clearly the
objective has to be a global economic
growth I think Bob Rice mentioned this
at lunch I strongly agree interest rates
are too high everywhere the world is
awash in global over capacity and a
whole slew of manufacturing and
agricultural industries the IMF and my
judgment inappropriately has pushed
austerity measures on Asia when they
ought to be pushing more growth oriented
measures interest rates as I say have to
be brought down clearly to prevent the
trade imbalances from intensifying
and global overcapacity from causing
bigger problems in commodity producing
industries and others we need growth
that ought to be the objective here and
everywhere else
but longer-term it's a matter of dealing
with some of the structural trade issues
that I mentioned earlier I talked about
market access it's very difficult to do
the only leverage we have is really
access to our own markets and I know how
difficult that is to use and how careful
we need to you to be in using it but one
way or another we have to find a way to
work forcing foreign markets open I
strongly believe instead of austerity
for example the IMF would be insisting
on long-term structural reforms
including market opening as a condition
for some of the financial assistance
packages they're providing mostly in
Asia now instead of the short term
austerity perhaps also insisting than
some of the UNAC excess capacity be
eliminated I strongly believe we have to
keep our anti-dumping laws they're far
from perfect there are they are abused
many times sometimes they're used as
purely a protectionist device but in a
world that already over capacity breeds
dumping and and it's already just
showing some signs of doing so in some
industries so all of the trade laws we
have available to us
coupled with it Evert policies we have
use our leverage to force markets open
around the world in my judgment has to
be the the underpinnings of our future
trade policy in this country obvious
solution
yes and now the market on January 14th
will lose 20% of value
Robert rice advising Warren Buffett once
again I think we I think what we're
hearing and I certainly endorsed this if
I have my chance at lunch to go to to
some detail but the short term first
order priority is to get the global
economy moving again
and when you have 40% of the globe in
recession or worse and about 60% the
globe and heading toward recession if
not in recession it is very difficult to
talk with a straight face about the
trade imbalance and expect anything to
happen that's any good we've got to use
fiscal and monetary policy in this
country and other countries to push our
economies our global economies forward
get out of the reverse gear that some
many economies are now in and that
includes International Monetary Fund
policies which have been skewed toward
austerity toward simply keeping money in
countries at the cost of enormous
contraction and recession in the interim
period I think we do have to do
something about hot money moving around
the globe that is inhibiting trade not
encouraging trade I do it Reid with
Larry and other sentiments that have
been expressed number three in terms of
making sure to the extent possible but
it's difficult that other countries are
playing by the same trade rules and
opening themselves up to our exports we
have tribes the clinton ministration has
tried a number of times with japan
threatening under Section 301 under many
different informal and formal legal
auspices to get other countries to open
their markets it's a very long slog it
doesn't happen easily we have to keep
pushing there's no magic bullet there
and finally number four and I think it's
very important that Warren started the
discussion here we've got to make sure
that there are adjustment mechanisms for
people who are whether they are old
horses or young turks I don't care who
they are there
going to be people who are burdened by
trade who are going to get worse jobs
even if they do get new jobs those jobs
because they don't have the education
they don't have the training they don't
have the transportation they don't have
the wherewithal they're not going to be
getting good jobs when they lose the old
ones now we've got to make sure that
they are taken care of
it may mean ultimately some sort of
retraining education it doesn't mean by
the way we should not treat people who
lose their jobs because of trade
differently from people who lose their
jobs because of anything else it is
wrong to have a separate Trade
Adjustment Assistance mechanism because
it's almost impossible with all the
noise in the economy to figure out why
somebody loses a job whether it's
technology whether it's trade whether
it's corporate restructuring it doesn't
matter we need a fast and easy and
relatively painless there's always going
to be pain but far less painful system
by which people can move from one job to
the next job you have you works great
for the average but it doesn't work very
well for the average loyal service
industry worker there are a lot of those
people that are being put out of jobs
but at the same time it is a great
benefit to the economy and and when you
look at governing government's about
making tough choices and allocation of
resources there are a lot of people that
are going to be out of work and put out
of work by by the effective trade
including not just the oil service but
that 30 year old worker who only knows
how to run a loan for thirty years
thirty years of running a little brats
he's 55 or she's 55 so so the real
question that I've got is you know I
don't think we can solve these problems
by by imposing solutions from Washington
I know I know you agree with that but we
have to find a way to empower these
people to make their own decisions about
their career choices and where they're
going so how do we effectively empower
them without just putting them in a in a
fabulous rest home for the next fifteen
or thirty years obviously we need to put
them back to work
you think there are significant problems
with nations that are made of the city
and I said I think that Japan's decision
to force their consumers to pay high
prices for things that you manufacture
here first Japan as much as us
nonetheless when they combine that with
policy to try to increase a lot of
exports they said the United States
produces I think understandable citizen
that's what different than saying we
want a Washington bate bureaucracy to be
managing every single detail of the
International economy so I would ask
them handle at that point that this
battle could leave
now more on how global trade affects the
US economy
you'll hear from Warren Buffett chairman
and CEO of Berkshire Hathaway David
Smith public policy director for the
afl-cio the New Republic senior editor
Greg Easterbrook and the Columbia
University economics professor this
segment of the day-long event is about
an hour here's what's ahead next
President Clinton's remarks on via
university of new york is renowned
economist whose work as beard and dozens
of books articles and essays great
Easterbrook over here is a senior editor
at New Republic magazine his most recent
book is beside still waters which has
been widely praised book that explores
the relationship between faith and
science he's here today as well because
in 1995 he published a book that I
consider to be a landmark book on the
environment called a moment on the earth
David Smith on your left my right is the
director of the public policy department
at the national headquarters at the of
the afl-cio a significant contributor to
the national policy debate informing us
on what he believes needs to be done
David is also a senior fellow at the
20th century fund he's a former
professor at the University of
Massachusetts who had this right and the
new School of Social Research in a
former facility city of New York New
York and an aide in the United States
Senate professor Bhagwati
let's start with you you've heard what
John Cavanaugh said I sort of nodding
there as he was going for it I presume
that's because he was saying something
it's important
let me just ask you do you think we have
a moral responsibility that the answer
is yes I'm gonna meet that goal is it a
door trade well
I'm jealous for me up in last Marlo
Smith I was a terry crouppen
there wasn't one but was aspiring to be
one another one asked me if I'd you know
I was active in backpack and I said the
only backpack I knew was my daughter's
the question you ask is this interesting
of course I do believe in aid and I
think it's terribly important providers
well focus to the recipient and result
of the troubles which they have so in
that sense I do think we do need to
remain involved in Russia it's not my
field but trade is in the end the most
important thing because in the end dole
outs are not really a way in which you
confer dignity and sustained growth on
people you want them to be able to to
participate in an integrated world
economy and to be able to earn a living
and to prosper and I do believe that
trade is a moral cause the trade does
lead to a great deal of prosperity
around the world if you see if you take
all the poorer countries in the post-war
period the ones which were
inward-looking didn't want to integrate
with the world economy within one
foreign investment and one trade towards
the children integration integration of
the world economy would mean
disintegration of your own national
economy all those countries wound up
really reasonably poor were unreasonably
poor and did not manage to eliminate
poverty and in there include the country
I come from originally India and a whole
lot of other countries which really were
outward oriented like the Far Eastern
countries did manage to impact on
poverty and I think those that is
exactly what we also need to remember at
our end as we think in terms of all
these kinds of worries because those
worries have come from thee for parts of
the world at the beginning of the
post-war period they've died out they're
mostly you and the policymakers have
come around to appreciating the benefits
of free trade and so on
unfortunately welcome to our friend and
you know people are beginning to worry
about integration of the world economy
and have all these fears with some which
we have heard and some of which are
justified which need institutional
responses but I think trade is an engine
of growth prosperity and is therefore
for that reason a moral cause
that great you believe gentlemen we do
that but also today laborer I think the
illusion that were the great stars the
pollution environmental destruction of
the world although we really make
environmental mistakes which will be
held accountable if you travel the world
you very rapidly discover that it is the
developing nations not the industrial
ones that are there polluted countries
the United States in the last 25 years
we've had steady declines in air
pollution water pollution toxic
pollution and all the major categories
during the same period that we've had a
growth economy we it's it's in my mind
the greatest national achievement of the
last 25 years of American life is that
we've managed to shift the previous
trend of increasing pollution converted
into a trend of decreasing pollution
make growth and and pollution decline
the two reconciled and show you don't
have to pollute your environment in
order to have a successful economy and
and you here in Nebraska which is
cleaner with every passing year your air
is cleaner your water is cleaner and at
most environmental trends are good can
be proud of the part you've played in
that if you travel the developing world
the trends are all the rivers things are
getting worse in most nations the level
of water pollution in the rest of the
world is staggering a a billion point
two people don't have access to safe
drinking water in the world
w-h-o World Health Organization figures
show that last year four billion
children under the age of five died from
indoor smoke pollution in the world
obviously not one single one of them in
the United States or Western Europe but
most of the world still heats indoors
with wood or agricultural waste products
unlike the clean energy that we use in
in the West the pollution is a problem
much more of the developing world than
it is of the developed and to the extent
that our exports can help them we can
export a few things one what most
prominently the idea in the knowledge
that it is now possible based on the
technology of the last 20 or 30 years to
have economic growth in reducing
pollution simultaneously this was not
possible at the turn of the century say
when the United States was furiously
polluting its own environment it is
technically possible
now we have to export that idea to the
rest of the world by trading with the
rest of the world we can increase the
national national income of the rest of
the world in economic studies are are
pretty clear on the fact that after a
certain level and most economists put it
around five thousand dollars a US per
capita gross domestic product pollution
begins to decline and economic success
continues if nations need the material
prosperity with which to buy the
pollution control devices that we have
in the West and and finally they just
need access to the your look is one that
we have a lot of expertise and talent we
can provide either as a or estranged and
the environmental problems in developing
different than the ones that we
typically do with here we're concerned
about particulars in the air at the bar
oh oh sure most most of the world's
developing nations at least the ones
with rapidly growing populations
especially in the equatorial world are
dealing with the problems that haven't
existed in the Western world for a
hundred years access to safe drinking
water urban sewage control basic control
of release of toxins into drinking water
area and especially the the use of
indoor open fires cooking fires for
heating and heating and cooking just we
can't even imagine what it's like if
you've heard if you've ever accidentally
left the flue closed in your fireplace
when you've started a fire and had that
five minutes when there's smoke in the
house and everybody's choking that's how
a billion to two billion people live on
a regular basis in the world today
because indoor fires is the only source
of heat and cooking fuel they have and
we need I think the environmental
movement has trouble coming to terms
with this sometimes because it requires
you to advocate resource consumption and
industrial development for a large share
of the world there isn't there
given population increases there really
isn't a soft past solution to this the
rest of the world needs industrial
growth but as long as it's industrial
growth in the direction of the clean
technologies that now dominate growth in
the Western world there's no reason why
developing nations can't have reasonable
control over their environments and
economic prosperity at the same time
clearly provides win-win-win
opportunities that he could use that
phrase so that's a job in the United
States jobs and I really need to solve
the problems well as an environmental
benefit and that was the developed of
the the relative efficient rates between
coal-fired power plants in China and
coal-fired power plants and officials
six times more efficient the United
States than in China and they they are
producing a tremendous amount of
greenhouse gases a lot of you example oh
yes if you're concerned about the
greenhouse effect and you should be the
scientific case for it is continuing to
get stronger you should be especially
concerned because if for moral reasons
we almost have to root for the
consumption of more fossil fuel in the
world in the next generation in order to
bring Worli equitable living standards
to the rest of the world the developing
world for the next one to two
generations until human population
stabilizes simply must burn more fossil
fuel
well how what standard are they going to
do it at are they going to do it at an
inefficient turn of the century standard
or at the standard we have here in the
United States if you go to China which
is now the world's largest producer and
consumer of coal the typical coal-fired
power plant there of which they're
building a thousand megawatts of
capacity I think a week now at this
point adding burns at 6% thermal
efficiency power plants the United
States and and 6% thermal efficiency
without any acid rain controls in the
United States are plants now operated 38
to 39 percent thermal efficiency with
acid rain reduction this means that in
China they burn six times as much coal
to produce the same unit of electricity
as we do here in the United States thus
emitting six times the greenhouse gases
if we could succeed in nothing else than
exporting our standard of efficiency to
them they could cut their coal
consumption to 1/6 what it is and that
would actually have be a greater
contribution to greenhouse gas reduction
than anything we could do in the United
States right now
David works at the afl-cio one things
that this great thing by afl-cio is a
perception I think with most people in
the country is that Labor's against free
trade first of all I'm not let you speak
as whether or not that's case but the
second thing that I find about very
interesting about there's not no work
heard is that the strongest advocates
work on moral basis for working
standards in the rest of the world is
afl-cio anything is on the first
question or on any other question talk
to us about what you think makes a good
drink boxes Thank You senator and thank
you for pulling this extraordinarily
provocative session together I think we
all appreciate it I've been sufficiently
provoked that I may ramble a little bit
but let me try to try to get to you your
two questions it seems to me it's
important to come back to a couple
things that that Larry shimmering and
Bob Rice tried to tried to head us
toward I think it's a mistake to think
about this as a problem of trade policy
the process of global integration has
created a number of problems the problem
that that Larry described in that that
my friend bill greider will talk about
more in the third panel the the problem
which Larry describes a problem of
excess capacity but also ought to be
thought about as a problem of
insufficient demand one of the things
which we have decided to do using the
instrument the very blunt instrument of
terrible IMF policy is to tell
developing countries facing a currency
crisis created in large part by some of
the speculative runs on currency that
barb described we've said to those
countries you have no choice reduce
domestic consumption raise domestic
interest rate stifle domestic demand and
export to the United States in order to
earn enough hard currency to to pay off
your debt
that's a crazy development boss maybe we
can get away with it once or twice when
we say to a substantial chunk of the
International economy the only way you
can thrive is to export to the US to bad
things one we're not improving standards
or living in Indonesia in Malaysia in
Korea we're not creating the kind of
growth in domestic consumption that that
Greg correctly describes as a spur to
lots of other things that we care about
we're also creating an intolerable
situation here one that's not
politically sustainable whatever one
thinks about trade policy that the
current imbalance in trading outcomes is
driven by crummy economic policy and the
notion that we can fix it by tweaking
here with with domestic or even
international trade policy I think is a
mistake and second that the question
that Bob raised when he was putting this
panel together is do we have a moral
obligation to trade more or trade less I
think that's the wrong question let me
just talk a little bit about that the
objective of economic activity ought to
be that people get better off well
trained economists like Jagdish and me
used to believe jugdish I think still
does believe that it's a self-fulfilling
prophecy that more trade makes people
better off I think we need to look at
the evidence and and pay a little bit of
attention to the contradiction between
the evidence and the theory here more
trade is not making American steel
workers better off there is now more
imported steel coming into the United
States than this market can sustain Bob
said 6,000 actually gets 10,000 layoffs
in that industry now and I want to come
back something Warren said then I'll be
quiet
wine described rest home for old horses
suggesting that folks who are displaced
by trade are you know they're the buggy
whip manufacturers they are in fact the
horses faced with with the tractors in
the American steel industry today and a
lot of the rest of
American manufactured that simply isn't
true the American steel industry went
through a gut-wrenching hundreds of
thousands of jobs costing billions of
dollars of investment costing renovation
of itself during the 1980s this industry
is the world's low-cost highest-quality
producer today but it can't compete with
a ruble the value of which has sunk
through the floor with a roopa that was
devalued by 80% and in the process of a
few months and with a managed currency
in Japan and to suggest that steel
workers who are displaced by that set of
phenomenal this isn't a trade policy
problem this is an economic failure
problem our old horses that we need to
figure out how to take care of in a in a
gentle and kind way I think misses the
point and I and I think the problem here
is that thinking about trade policy
rather than making the international
economic regime work so that standards
of living improve in Bangkok as well as
in Omaha that's our task and that's the
moral question we ought to ask ourselves
we're gonna get into a question accident
we had students please call on him he
found out that Warren was gracious
enough participating the conference we
had on the issue of connection between
savings and welcome so all juniors and
seniors high school and the first
question being asked
was mr. Buffett there with all due
respect our most wealthy people jerks I
tried it the question putting in at
lunch you have to be careful about
averages that he said that the average
Shaquille O'Neal and his height we had
six point two feet of height having said
that the United States of America is an
enormously wealthy country the
wealthiest country on earth other
countries and adulthood to where we used
to be and weren't answer I thought was
quite relevant both for individuals in
from nation needs answered was his
experience was that wealth disallows you
to be a little world when you already
work so what you're a jerk to begin with
one of the reasons that I but I could be
where we come out of this question of
moral obligation but I can think that
one of the things that's very
encouraging and causes me to be
optimistic about our being able to
figure it out is United States of
America underlying economics is hold
people with very good values and want to
do the right thing and do care about
what's going on the rest of the world
prep this war and I'll give you a chance
if you choose to respond to me I know I
agree with them totally on the steel
industry actually that planet I referred
to a Norfolk run by new core and new
cars probably as efficient steel
producer as you will find in the world
but if you change the value of the yen
enough for a number of other currencies
it can it can even though you're turning
out more steel per per man-hour than
then your competitor someplace else if
if they're current if you're if your
currency rises or the other Falls
depending on how you look at it to a
sufficient point even even the the mill
with the most output per hour and can
fall victim to the guy that that has the
chief currency and there's no question
about that so I I didn't mean my horse
example to extend quite as far I I and
incidentally Bob's exactly right I've
always said on that lifestyles of the
rich and famous instead of showing all
these houses and you know the boats are
what sort of thing what the rich can
really do that you can't do is when they
hate somebody they can cause lots of
trouble I mean what you know if you
don't like your brother-in-law you don't
send them a card at Christmas or
something the sort but they sue they get
up early in the morning and again they
got retinues of lawyers you can go on
hating for dozens of years with
and you people can't touch it so I happy
so they're a huge advantage the Bob was
referring to because I think it's
important and I asked you just to join
me in this framework which Bob heard
before the to think about the issue a
bit and let's just have a little flight
of fancy here and assume that it's 24
hours before Bob was born and a GD
appeared and he looked at this little
embryo and he said you know you look
very promising and anything you might
grow up me president United States who
knows but you're going to be born in 24
hours and you're going to get to
establish the political social the
economic rules of this world into which
you're going to emerge at 24 hours to
think about any rules you establish are
going to be rules for you your children
your grandchildren for a hundred years
to come can't change them have to get
out and you get to think about it and
let me know in 24 hours and of course
Bob being a little suspicious would say
what's the catch and the genie would say
well there is a catch you don't know
whether you're going to be born black or
white you don't know whether you're
going to be born male or female you
don't know whether you're going to be
able bodied or infirm you don't know
whether you're going to be brighter
[ __ ] you don't know whether you're
gonna be born in the United States or
Bangladesh all you know is in 24 hours
you get to reach in this barrel with 6
billion balls in it roughly and you pull
out one and you never get to change it
you're going to participate in what I
call the ovarian lottery and at that
point it's the most important event in
your life nothing will remotely touch it
I mean all the things that happen
subsequently whether you get into
Harvard or not or whether you get a
raise or not whether you marry the right
spouse are not nothing compares to
pulling that ball out of the barrel now
what kind of a world do you want to
establish because you do get this at the
rules you just
know what your position is going to be
within that well I would suggest that
we'd all answer that somewhat
differently but we'd have some common
goals in answering that one of the goals
we would have would be to have a world
that would lead to an abundance of goods
and services and one where that
abundance would grow over time on a per
capita basis so that they would be
greater for our children and our
grandchildren we'd won a world that was
free of fare to the degree possible not
just fear of getting mugged tonight but
the fear of old age and the fear of
crippling illness fear of unemployment
whatever it might be we would want a
world that caused the Jack Welch's and
the Bill Gates as long after they had
all the money they needed to still jump
out of bed at 6:00 in the morning trying
to figure out better things to do and
produce more goods and services but we
would also want a world where the person
with the 70 IQ and who just wasn't well
adapted for a market society couldn't
arbitrage currencies or anything of the
sort all those wonderful things that
come with the free market that that
person in turn would share in this
abundance of goods and services